this video is going to be a beauty if
you know of any shortcuts of
multiplication by 11 12 13 and so on
please forget those for a while before
we move on to the shortcuts we try
multiplying 23 with 11 in the normal way
we write 23 and then write a 11 under it
23 times 1 is 23 we leave a place here
and 23 times 1 again is 20 3 3 5 2 23
times 11 is 253 took us about seven
seconds while we could have done it in
two seconds let's move on to the
shortcut of multiplying a number with 11
23 times 11 to begin we write the first
digit as is 2 to get the next digit we
simply add 2 with 3/5 and then we write
the last digit 3 bingo we have our
answer 253 it's easy first digit sum and
the last digit with the same logic try
multiplying 34 with 11 first digits 3 as
is then 3 plus 4 7 and the last digit 4
34 times 11 is 374 does this trick of
multiplication with 11 work with
three-digit numbers as well let's try
123 times 11 first digit as this one
then the sum of these 2 1 plus 2 is 3
then the sum of these 2 2 plus 3 is 5
and the last digit as is 120 3 times 11
is 1353 have you seen a quicker way I
doubt it
does it work with 4 digit numbers as
well okay let me say this case
early this trick works with any and
every number try multiplying 1421 with
11 using the shortcut we just saw the
first digit 1 is written as is then the
sum of these two numbers 1 plus 4 is 5
then the sum of these two numbers 4 plus
2 is 6 we continue this until we reach
the last digit sum of these two numbers
will be 2 plus 1 which equals 3 and then
the last digit 1 is written in the end
1421 times 11 is equal to 15,000 631
what about 567 times 11 this one's
simple as well just that it involves
some carrying over first digit 5 as is 5
plus 6 is 11 we write 1 and carry the
other 1 over 6 plus 7 is 13 3 written
under here and the 1 is carried over and
we write the last digit 7 here 5137 is
not the answer
don't forget the numbers that we have
carried over 7 3 1 plus 1 is 2 and 1
plus 5 is 6 567 times 11 is 6237 so this
was super easy but that's not the best
part the best part is that
multiplication by 12 13 and so on also
use a similar concept let's see that on
a new page 123 times 12 understand the
steps well we are looking at multiplying
a number with 12 we write the first
number as this one then we multiply the
first digit of the number by 2 and add
the next digit so we multiply 1 with 2
and add the product with the
next digit which is 2 2 plus 2 is 4 this
step remains constant until we reach the
last digit so next we multiply the
second digit 2 with 2 and add it to the
third digit which is 3 4 plus 3 is 7 and
in the end we multiply the last digit by
2 3 times 2 is 6 123 multiplied by 12 is
equal to 1476 first digit as is then
multiplied by 2 and add to the next
digit until we reach the last digit and
then multiply the last digit by 2 what
will five thousand six hundred and
ninety two times twelve be equal to
first digit five as is then five times 2
plus 6 16 6 and a 1 carried over then 6
times 2 plus 9 21 1 and a 2 carried over
then 9 times 2 plus 2 xx 0 and 2 carried
over and the last digit multiplied by 2
equals 4 don't forget to add the numbers
we have carried over 4 0 2 plus 1 is 3 2
plus 6 is 8 and 1 plus 5 is 6 68
thousand three hundred and four is our
answer
by the way why are we multiplying it
with 2 we take the 2 of the 12 with this
you can even guess the shortcut for
multiplying a number with 13 yes we
multiply a digit by 3 and add it to the
next one easy try out these three
examples to check if you have really
understood the shortcuts 263 times 11
1452 times 12 and 569 times 13 I give
you 20 seconds go
okay let's see if you got the right
answers 263 times 11 first digit 2 as is
2 plus 6 is 8 6 plus 3 is 9 and the last
digit 3 as is 1450 2 times 12 we use the
multiplication by 12 shortcut first
digit 1 as is 1 times 2 plus 4 is 6 4
times 2 plus 5 is 13 5 times 2 plus 2 is
12 and the last digit 2 is multiplied
with 2 to get fall next 569 times 13 for
13 it's multiplied by 3 and add the
product to the next digit the first
digit is 5 which is written as this 5
times 3 plus 6 is 21 1 and a 2 carried
over 6 times 3 plus 9 is 27 7 & a 2
carried over and as it's 13 we multiply
the last digit by 3 9 times 3 is 27 7
and a 2 carried over seven nine three
seven five hundred and sixty nine times
13 is seven thousand three hundred
ninety seven if you got all the answers
right well done now all you need to do
is keep practicing to achieve a better
speed on the other hand if you haven't
got all the answers right it's not a big
deal watch this lesson again and try out
random examples practice is the key to
understanding and improving your ability